When did you first encounter Budo?
When I was a small child.
People before the Second World War all did.
They started practice in primary school.
Furthermore, in my family a style of archery was transmitted.
At the back of our house there was an impressive makiwara.
I had the red and black bow that belonged to my father when he was as a child
and I learned the basics with it.
That was in  your own home?
In our house.
It was always like that.
The style was called Heki-Ryu Chikurin-ha Ban-pa
It is a very rare school.
It was taught in Tsushima to the upper class Samurai
who earned more than 500 koku of rice per year.
Although we had a shooting range in our home,
we didn't accept outside students.
It was part of our family education.
Everybody used to do this.
Only at home.
Yes, at home.
You had a dojo in your house
and that's where you'd practice.
The same is true for horsemanship.
A proper samurai would have a stable and practice there.
You wouldn't have to go to school for that.
Of course there are also things that you go to school for.
Was this in Tokyo?
Tokyo, in Jyugaoka.
I was born in the University of Tokyo hospital,
when it was still in Nishikatamachi.
My father was at the Tokyo Imperial University at that time.
In 1933 we moved to Jiyugaoka.
The house was large and Jiyugaoka at that time was still countryside.
I started to practice with the sword in primary school
and when I was a student I also practiced Karate with Funakoshi Gichin Sensei.
That was Shotokan-ryu.
Shotokan.
This is how people called it.
Sensei did not call it like that.
Shoto was Funakoshi Gichin Sensei's pen name.
It is the same kanji as the one used for the Shoto district in Shibuya.
Shoto means “the wind rustling in the pine needles sounds like waves”.
Did you meet Funakoshi Sensei?
Yes, many times.
When Funakoshi Sensei went home from the Dojo, I also went to see him off two or three times.
What was your motivation for entering the Ueshiba Dojo?
I had known about it since childhood.
I'd often hear about it during the war,
when I was in 3rd or 4th grade.
Many famous people were studying this exceptional Budo.
Yano Ichiro, the former president of Dai-Ichi Seimei, was a close friend of my father.
He had started Kendo as a child at Hibiya High School and did it all the way through and Tokyo University.
then he became the chairman of the Businessmen’s Association and he was also holding the highest degree (Hanshi) of the Butokukai.
Mr Yano said about O Sensei that
“Compared to Ueshiba Morihei Sensei I am like a baby”
That's what I heard as a child.
Then when I went to Manchuria in 1941,
It was the 10th anniversary of the founding of the Manchu state.
There was a meeting of Budoka from all  over Japan.
There was a large demonstration at the Hall of Martial Arts in front of the Last Emperor of China.
I heard that the demonstration that Ueshiba Sensei gave that time was incredible.
I was supposed to attend too,
but my mother and my sister talked too much and we missed it.
But my cousin saw it
How old were you?
I was twelve.
From that point, things became difficult because of the war.
A short while after the topic came up again
during the spring break at Waseda University Karate Club.
There were talks about a famous master called Ueshiba.
That Admiral Takeshita was a patron of his,
and that he could throw foreign officers in the blink of an eye.
Harada Mitsusuke who is in London now
and Ōshima Tsutomu who is now in America were also there when we talked about it.
Mr Takeda, who was the captain at the time said:
“Now that you mention it, a relative of mine did the illustrations for the book on Budo by Ueshiba-Sensei.”
I forgot her name, but I knew her well.
He said he could get me the dōjō’s address if was interested.
It was is Wakamatsu 102.
It was a short walk from Waseda University.
The same place as today's Hombu Dojo?
Yes, nowadays' Wakamatsu-cho 17-18, but it used to be number 102.
Did you need a guarantor to sign up?
No, it was already after the war.
Generally there were too few people to even make up a dojo.
So you would just have to go visit to be admitted.
Were there still refugees living in the dojo?
There were, for another 3 or 4 years.
It wasn't really a shelter, just one family.
From the 80 tatamis, 20 were partitioned off,
and they lived on these 20 twenty tatamis.
What was the practice schedule like?
Practice was from Monday to Saturday.
In the morning from 6:30 am to 7:30 am,
and the evening one was from 6:30 pm to 7:30 pm, that was it.
Then you could practice for yourself freely for the whole day.
Because Kisshomaru Sensei was employed and had to go to work.
It was because there were only 5 or 6 students,
and big corporations no longer subsidized the dojo.
It wasn't that kind of time anymore.
Could you tell us about O Sensei's whereabouts at the time?
O Sensei was always on the move between Iwama, Tokyo, and other places.
When he went to the Kansai Area he would come back to Tokyo and then continue to Iwama.
Then he would come back to Tokyo and go to Kansai again.
Suita in Osaka, Tanabe in Wakayama, Hikitsuchi Michio’s dōjō in Shingu.
That’s what he did all the time.
When you started, was it already called "Aikido"?
When I was admitted it was not called that yet
It was called “Aiki-Budo”.
There was no official name.
When I was a student at Waseda university,
I wanted to create a club.
Ueshiba Sensei started to give seminars at his dojo.
I wanted to invite O Sensei to teach like that.
But in order to advertise this we needed the name of a professor,
so we asked Mr Tomiki.
To call it “Aiki-Budō” was problematic because of the times,
so I chose “Aikido”.
But even before then it was called “Aikidō”.
Under the Butokukai, it was practiced in the section called “Aikidō”.
Wasn't "Aikido" meant as an umbrella term to gather different empty-handed system?
No, that was not the case, it was Ueshiba Sensei’s Aikido.
My cousin brought me the programme of the 1942 demonstration in Manchuria,
I lost it but it was billed as “Ueshiba-Ryu Aikijutsu”.
This name also appears in a novel.
Some kind of children’s fiction.
Guillaume started Aikido in André Nocquet's group, did you know Nocquet?
When Mr Nocquet joined, I think I was in my mid 20s.
Mr Nocquet was around 40.
Before Mr Nocquet came,
Mr Mochizuki Minoru had been to France in 1951,
invited by Sakurazawa Nyoichi.
Over there he called himself "George Ohsawa"
The George Ohsawa of macrobiotics.
It all started when Mr Mochizuki was invited to France by him.
The year after, Abe Tadashi went.
It was in 1952.
Mr Nocquet had learned from Abe Tadashi.
After Mr Nocquet came, several Frenchmen started coming.
The French embassy was also involved.
They sponsored an Aikido demonstration at the Ueshiba Dojo.
There are some photographs.
Mr Nocquet trained under Abe Sensei for a few years, he found it amazing and decided to come.
There was an article about him in the Yomiuri newspaper.
At the beginning he practiced Judo, and after he mastered it,
he started to practice with Abe Tadashi for several years.
He wanted to practice more and came to Japan, where he stayed for 3 or 4 years.
André Nocquet used to say that your nikyo was very painful!
I was young!
I was only in my twenties, I was practicing from morning to evening.
I did not get a job, but dedicated myself to the exclusive study of Aikido and Japanese Budo.
While Nocquet-san was here he also did a demonstration.
I remember that when he returned
– at that time you would leave Japan by ship from Yokohama –
he left with an American ship and we went to see him off.
When he went home he was perhaps 44 or 45 years old.
I don't know what he did just after going home.
I went to Italy in October 1964
and in 1965, I was invited to France by Noro.
That time, Mr Nocquet came with another person to greet me, and he watched the demonstration.
Was it at this time that public demonstrations started?
The first public demonstrations took place on the roof of Takashimaya.
It was done there because there was no other place where to do a demonstration.
Of course the Budokan didn't exist.
There was no place that could host a demonstration.
It was not yet the time when you could rent the Hibiya Kōkaidō at great expense.
After the demonstration at Takashimaya, followed those at Mitsukoshi and on the roof of Shibuya's Tokyu department store.
Then you could rent a lecture hall in a beauty school or at a newspaper publisher,
different places like that.
But which was the proper first such occasion the Aikikai put on?
If you look at the records you should find it.
It seems that Kisshomaru Doshu had a hard time getting O Sensei to approve of such public displays.
O Sensei was reluctant to open Aikido to the public.
Originally it was not something that was made available to the public.
It was the same in Daito-ryu.
Takeda Sokaku Sensei did not disclose things openly either.
None of the old Budoka did that.
They only showed it to privileged people, not to outsiders.
It used to be called Otome-waza.
Otome-waza are the techniques that would not be allowed to be taught outside one’s feudal domain.
It's completely understandable because it would put you at a disadvantage if you let outsiders learn your secrets.
Another reason was that if a teaching spread too far, it would deteriorate.
That’s why it was only taught to special people, very carefully.
It was that sort of time.